it was just brought to my attention that
Jeff Sessions grandson
Benjamin is an intern on our staff it's
not crazy yeah hello and welcome welcome
Benjamin we're hello mr. O'Brien right
yeah
how's the internship going before we
continue I'd like to read from a
prepared statement I don't think it's
necessary hmm dear esteemed colleagues
members of the Konan production staff
and studio audience it is a privilege to
serve on this fine program I assure you
it is a duty I do not take lightly god
bless these United States I'm glad
you're enjoying yourself I don't think
that was necessary but how was your
first week been
I don't recall okay how you getting
along with the other interns I am not at
liberty to say okay these are not
helpful answers sir are you accusing me
of stonewalling kind of what you're
doing mr. O'Brien
these are scurrilous scandalous scalawag
ulis accusations
okay those aren't words Benjamin calm
down ah Benjamin Zachariah zebediah
sessions have served in my capacity has
unpaid intern with owner fulfilling all
my duties be it fetching rhubarb pie for
mr. Richter or retrieving your daily
supply of 500 moist towelettes this is
an outrage all right okay we get it you
imply that I could engage in obstruction
is about as believable as as a crawfish
dunking a basketball through a sardine
bar all right fine fine just enjoy the
rest of your internship sorry I brought
it up Thank You mr. O'Brian
now if you'll excuse me I'm taking a
lunch break with my fellow intern Boris
it's not suspicious it's normal
workplace friendship
thank you very much Benjamin
you